IT’S THE ONE PRESIDENT
MENTIONING ABOUT FOOTBALL, AND
WHILE HE’S ON THAT TOPIC, I WANT
TO GET A QUICK ANALYSIS.
JOE BIDEN DID HIS DRIVE-UP
TOWN HALL TONIGHT,
ARI FLEISCHER, LET’S BRING YOU
IN FOR THE ANALYSIS.
ONE QUESTION ABOUT THE MONTH
SAYING IT’S HYSTERICAL
XENOPHOBIA AND FEARMONGERING, IS
THAT IN THE TANK FOR BIDEN, THEY
CAN’T EVEN ASK THAT QUESTION?
>> NO QUESTION ON THAT, NO
QUESTION ON WHY DID YOU SAY IN
THE OVAL OFFICE OF JANUARY 2017
AT THE LOGAN ACT SHOULD BE
INVOKED AGAINST MICHAEL FLYNN?
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT FRACKING BY A
VOTER AND THE BORDER SAID TO
HIM, ARE YOU AGAINST FRACKING?
AND HE SAID NO.
THEN ANDERSON COOPER FOLLOWED UP
AND SAID WAIT A MINUTE, YOU
PREVIOUSLY SAID HE WANT TO GET
RID OF IT.
SO BASICALLY JOE BIDEN IN THE
SPACE OF 52ND SET I’M NOT
AGAINST IT NOW BUT I WILL BE
AGAINST IT.
I WANT TO GET RID OF IT.
HE STILL ALL OVER THE MAP WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT.
AMERICAN ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
BROUGHT TO US VIA FRACKING,
REALLY IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Sean: AND MANDATORY MASKS.
HE FLIPPED AND FLOPPED BACK AND
FORTH AGAIN ON THE ISSUE OF
MASKS.
BUT IN THIS CRITICAL TIME.
WHERE THE PRESIDENT TEN DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST CASE OF
CORONAVIRUS IMPLEMENTED THE
TRAVEL BAN, TEN DAYS, THE FIRST
CASE IN THE U.S., THEN THE
QUARANTINE, FIRST IN 50 YEARS,
HE SPENT MONTHS CALLING IT
HYSTERICAL XENOPHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I’D LIKE TO
KNOW, DID HE DO IT BECAUSE HE
WANTED HUNTER TO GET ANOTHER
$1.5 BILLION DEAL FROM THE BANK
OF CHINA?
LEGITIMATE QUESTION AGAIN THAT
HE HAS NOT BEEN ASKED.
>> AND IN THAT ISSUE THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THE
MAP AS WELL.
REMEMBER NANCY PELOSI AND
MAYOR de BLASIO URGING PEOPLE
TO GO OUT TO CHINA TOWN BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO MAKE THE CASE
THAT REPUBLICANS WERE BIGOTS?
SO THEY ENCOURAGED, GET OUT.
THAT WAS THE END OF FEBRUARY.
THE REVISION ISN’T THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO TELL HOW MUCH CONFUSION